hey guys today I'm going to introduce to
the importance of a mysterious woman
from the Shadowlands being a shy in the
Far East today I'm going to talk about
quite huge role that she might play in
the upcoming season great also known as
way to the shadow appeared in second
season in only a few scenes which was
more than enough to realize that she has
some special capabilities some sort of
supernatural abilities as she seems to
build magical powers of prophecy and
clairvoyance Bishop Rossiter knowledge
about Jorah being a former spy for King
Robert with your knowledge about Zara's
and Dark Souls and priests theft over
the nurses dragons while she also kind
of her share of Jorah being infected
with dread in and usually fatal disease
definitely flash stiff and dead disease
known as greyscale as he had been
touched on the Rays by one of the stone
man if you don't remember
jarreau visited Quaid while she was
painting sailor to protect him while
passing across old Valyria with a
statement also travel close to the doom
must have protection which clearly means
that Quaid knows much more about this
mentioned disease more than others do
there's one interesting fact that I'm
going to highlight which is confirmed by
costume designer Michelle platen
according to Clayton Quaid's mask was
designed to display a stylistic link to
Melisandre because both of them are from
the region of a shy while the dress is
so both of them have the same things
agonal design motifs but that's not the
only thing that those two powerful and
mysterious women have in common both
Quaid and Melisandre are shadowed by
nurse practitioners of magic capable of
manipulating shadows to their will with
all this being said we can conclude that
Quaid has some special capabilities
which along with the fact that she knows
how to give protection to those who must
pass across old Valyria might mean that
she also knows how to cure one I've
already brought you a video about Jerome
immensely photos in which is accompanied
with the near Centurion a video in which
I've also provided your proofs of him
being cured which you can check out my
previous videos for all details with a
new and oscar-winner actor that we are
going to see in the upcoming season will
portray either a mysterious maester
Marvin who has traveled the lands beyond
the Narrow Sea and has spent eight years
in the East mapping distant lands
studying with warlocks and shadow
binders or will portray arrows and
archmaester Citadel who test
seeking their link in the art of healing
and with confirmation from Jim broadband
himself an actor who portrayed one of
those two characters that his scenes
were shared with John Bradley an actor
that plays similarly it's easy to assume
that those two the most likely find a
cure for Joris disease which accompanied
with the leaked plot in which stated
that Jorah will heal his Grace Kelly in
Oldtown makes this theory almost 100%
true I've already brought you a video
about Jim province appearance in one of
my previous videos so feel free to check
it out if you would like to know more
about his character death will appear in
five episodes of dota 7 and will appear
in one major scene of each of those five
episodes as he set himself in my opinion
this is highly possible outcome which
I'm almost sure will come true and it
would make sense the jury would come to
all time to seek help from maesters as
masters and healers managed to cure
daughter of Stannis Baratheon who was
infected by this disease as an infant
but it's also fact that those masters
and healers were brought from both sides
of the Narrow Sea
yes greyscale killed slowly it usually
takes many years to progress the
terminal state but long before that in
the mid to late stages of the disease
the infection will spread to cover all
the victims skin from head to toe which
leaves an infected person to live like
that for years living is one of the
stone man which means that jerk has to
find a cure as soon as possible less
time is syndra he was watching the
nearest Targaryen enter new calendar
living out of a Star Trek weapon he
started his new quest so the last time
I've seen Jorah he was leaning these
Dothraki the only city in the track is
sea located near the far north eastern
edge of the region which is far closer
to card a place in the Jura met a big
powerful woman Quaid who might know how
to cure his disease far closer than the
old town in which his disease will
apparently be cured as always let me
know your thoughts do you think the jury
will go straight to the Seven Kingdoms
and seek for help of minsters in old
town or do you think the jury will
firstly try to find a cure in Essos and
they look for Quaid who seems to be his
best chance of survival as not only that
sheep were shared of him being infected
but also knows how to protect people
from grayscale which might mean that she
knows how to cure this same disease let
me know your opinion in the comment
section below
Oh hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
channel and I hope to see in the next
piece
[Music]